guess who might be looking to put on his
happy face again bringing a little
laughter and a lot of Anarchy to the
mean streets of Gotham in the eight
decades since making his appearance in
the pages of Batman number one he's been
called everything from the Clown Prince
of Crime to the ace of knaves to put in
you know it's great about you put you
really put the fun in funeral
[Music]
he's also been called a psychopath who
just wants to watch the world burn Todd
Phillips and Joaquin Phoenix are calling
him Arthur Fleck though most of us have
come to know him simply as Joker by the
end of director Phillips and star
Phoenix's new film Joker that's
presumably the name and villainous
persona Arthur will take both apparently
anticipated film is still weeks away
from release it's already generating a
whirlwind of mostly positive press on
the festival circuit with many critics
praising Phoenix's turn as the titular
body as the best incarnation of the
Joker yet some are even speculating
Phoenix's performance may well met him
the best actor statue that somehow
eluded the actor throughout his diverse
and ambitious career understandably that
sort of praise already has people
buzzing about whether or not there's a
chance for a joker to and whether or not
Phoenix would be open to reprising his
role for it so will we ever see a Joker
sequel let's discuss Joker was pitched
and produced as a standalone project so
we can tell you right off the bat that
there is no immediate plan for a Joker
follow-up that being said director Todd
Phillips recently went on the record
with total film to state he would be
more than willing to make another Joker
movie if Phoenix were on board for the
project and he certainly makes it sound
like Phoenix might be considering the
possibility he told total film one thing
I will tell you I would do anything with
Joaquin any day of the week there is
nobody like him if he was willing to do
it and if people show up to this movie
and Warner's came to us and said you
know what if you guys could think of
something well I have a feeling that he
and I could think of something pretty
cool there's a lot to unpack in that
quote so before we get too ahead of
ourselves we can tell you that Phoenix
himself has neither confirmed nor denied
his interest and appearing in a Joker
sequel but what's interesting about
Phillips statement is how
where it is that both he and Phoenix had
a ton of fun bringing their version of
Joker to life
furthermore if one were inclined toward
a bit of conjecture you could also take
Phillips comment as a hint that the two
have already thought of where they take
the story and are just waiting to see
how Joker plays with audiences before
pursuing the next step
how's your job are you having any
negative thoughts for Phillips part he
seemingly already brought a
game-changing concept to the fray for
this first Joker as has been well
covered in the press this incarnation of
the Joker is a version of the character
that has nothing to do with any Joker
that's appeared before free from the
shackles of comic-book war TV and
cinematic Canon Phillips and Phoenix set
out to make the most of their blank
slate and craft a version of Joker the
likes of which have never been seen
before as for whether or not Phoenix
will return for a joker sequel we'll
just have to wait and see Robert
Pattinson certainly stoked the fires of
rumor ville by inadvertently alluding to
a possible cameo of Phoenix's Joker in
his upcoming the Batman but Phoenix has
been quite vocal about the emotional
toll the role took on him he told
reporters during a Venice Film Festival
presser that while playing Joker you
quote start to go a little mad even if
the studio wants a sequel the idea that
Phoenix would return to the role doesn't
seem guaranteed while it may be a
challenge for Phoenix to step back into
the make up for Joker - Phillips remarks
also imply the Joker's box office take
and critical reception may well
influence whether or not it happens
critics are already being very kind to
the film but the rest as it seems is up
to the movie-going public if you want to
see phoenix and phillips return for
joker - make sure you show joker a
little love when the film finally
arrives in theaters on october 4th when
you bring me out can you introduce me as
joker
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]